So I'm gonna talk about
React and web components how it is how it could
be and as I understand it because we all deal
with the web and things are always changing so I
kind of like to just put like a little time stamps
because this is as I understand it at this point
because there's more things that I'm actually
looking into that are pretty awesome coming
up and so I may give a talk about that later
all right so hi I'm Dwane a
JavaScript developer Advocateat Vonage
and I figured I want to come
and talk to you all about web components
so who's heard of web components let's raise your
hands and stuff oh very nice so I'm going to need
y'all afterwards to you know let me know who I
got wrong or your experiences and why or why not
you're using them and how are using them so then
I'm assuming who hasn't heard of web components
all right cool oh then why am I here giving a
talk cool so let me know if uh you find any value
in this and how you want to use it in the future
what have you all right so real quick how many
people are using react just curious all right okay
A good view all right cool so then this will make
sense of folks all right so now if you've ever
used like the video elements or the audio tag or
the details element I always found it interesting
how just by putting the tag and like a source for
the video element you get a fully functional video
player you didn't have to create the play button
or the pause button or listen for those events
the uh the mute any of that stuff it's all just
built in I always thought that was kind of awesome
same thing like the audio tag or even the details
details low-key one of my favorite HTML elements
you get a drop-down just built-in amazing stuff
all right that's just me I guess all right but
now imagine if you can create your own elements
right whatever you imagine being able to just
create something and you put it on a page and it
just works properly once you kind of understand
that everything becomes like a web component
so I like to make a lot of projects right
sometimes too many projects and for each
one of those I wanted to have an about page right
but having to create one individually for everyone
makes me not want to create anything and I just
want to make right and just make it put it out
there and so I was like hmm web components what
if I created a web component and called it Dwane
hyphen made to where I can put that on every
project and it's uh responsive so it does what
it needs to do I only need to do the work one
time and so what on each project I just call an
endpoint on each one of the different projects
fetch the data about the uh project and I and
it will format everything the way it needs to be
uh in the web component so I don't have to worry
about any of that stuff ever again so I can
create have the about page and I'm good to go
so that's one of them being reusable is one of
the main reasons I really like web components
another reason uh is that you can use the same
web component for multiple uses so kind of like
the Swiss Army Knife of like uh web stuff and so
another cool like element that I always thought
was amazing was the humble input button just by
changing the type you can radically change the
feel and the usage of it anybody else thought that
was cool is it just me I'm the web nerd here this
is cool okay maybe all right but I mean just like
you have a button and we all know working with
date and time is just terrible on the internet you
get a calendar that tells you the date that it is
now imagine having to do that yourself terrible
and then there's time and everything as well
and then we have the range and then this one the
color a Color Picker I don't know how you do that
in CSS that's just um that just seems like a lot
so again I just find these things fascinating
and I get to talk about them so along with
multi-use I like I said working with time
has always been like a pain for me so I was
just like I need to just do this thing once
and I'll be able to use it in whatever projects
I need to as well so if you can see like this
Sunday February 20th thing that's this web
component here this countdown timer 432 same
web component and then here also so I created
this web component to where depending on how
far in the future it is it will show you the
date and the time in your local time zone
and then once it reaches a certain like limit
that you can set I do like 60 minutes it will
turn into a countdown timer and then it'll count
down to the time where that's supposed to be again
in your time zone and there's like a whole lot of
time zone math stuff that I don't want to get into
again did it once it works never have to do it
again so again multi-use and uh being reusable
two of the things that I really like about web
components and those are the things that always
kind of running in the back of my mind as I'm
doing stuff like am I going to do this again
and if I can't if I'm going to do it again
will I do it in different ways or what have
you so that way for me makes a re good use
cases for turning something to web component
now one of the coolest web components I've ever
seen is model Dash viewer anybody seen this before
like yes you know how awesome it is so without
knowing any sort of 3D modeling or having to worry
about AR XR web XR virtual reality none of that
you get it all built in and then you can just kind
of mess around and play with it this is amazing
now you may be thinking that's that's that's cute
it's a little low-fi poly thing well they stepped
it up they actually scanned Neil Armstrong's suit
and it's it this is look at the reflection
in the helmet that is so cool and so again so
you can see the bottom of the shoes it's kind of
amazing and so just to get it working you import
a little bit of JavaScript because the browser
doesn't understand what model Dash viewer is
that's just not a regular element and so you need
the JavaScript to kind of tell it like okay don't
worry about it this JavaScript's going to tell you
what to do with it and then just here you put the
model-viewer tag and then of course we got to
be an accessible shout-out to Annuradha uh you put the
alt tag and then you put what it is and they even
have like a poster image and then the source is
the actual whoops the actual uh model for it and
then you get this this is amazing it's not only
for viewing like cool web 3D uh models also you
can put it in webxr so that's augmented reality
and virtual reality which are things that I've
been a big fan of as well so I was like I wonder
if I can extend this a little bit further and so
I created a webxr tic-tac-toe game with voice chat
and so again I know nothing about uh webXR
I think it's cool it's a lot of work and I'm not
I don't have the time to do that work now so I'm
going to have this web component do it for me and
so I'm just going to kind of play this video
really quickly so you can kind of check it out
because I if you want to play afterwards let me
know because it's deployed and I'll you know you
can beat me in tic-tac-toe I have swag and if you
beat me I'll give you shirts or something or socks
all right so here's a quick video so so you can
see right there on my tablet I have like the uh
virtual reality version of it and then I'm also
recording through my phone so you can also see the
augmented reality version and so what I'm doing
is playing a game of Tic-tac-toe and I'm sending
the moves back and forth uh through our bondage
apis and so I'm able to kind of keep each uh
board in sync with it and so it's not only is
it cool to like see it but you're also able to
pass information back and forth between it
and so I again I didn't have to worry about
any of this stuff it just worked and which was
amazing and then I think I'm gonna like win at
some point neither but there's also uh you can
enable audio chat because there's nothing more
than like hearing the person you're beating
like squeal and so all right so then that's
that and then it wins what have you all right
cool now professionally because we talked about
the stuff I did like personally cool things that I
thought would help with web components uh so I'm a
JavaScript developer Advocate at Vonage and
I handle a lot of the client SDK stuff and a good
use case for that is creating like chat apps right
and so instead of having people having to create
the different uh like the divs or the sections
for their chat app I figured well why not just
Encompass everything into different elements
so that each element is responsible for its
own actions and listening for events or sending
uh events and so like we have the VC messages
and that it lists all the different messages that
are sent in the chat then we have the VC members
that takes care of all the members who are there
and if they leave it removes them and if they come
in it adds them and then we have the VC text input
where it is you just put in your text message and
hit send and then we also have the VC typing
indicator which shows like who's typing while
they're typing what's cool is now let's say if
you wanted the VC members on the other side of
VC messages if they're just HTML tags so in your
HTML just move it to the other side and you're
good to go again you don't have to worry about
listening for advanced or anything they all handle
their own uh tasks that they're responsible for
so that's another cool thing so there's that uh
now another one uh this is actually like the
first one I created because uh like typing in
like numbers and like things is kind of a pain
because you have to listen for every button or
what have you so I was like well to make it
work with our client SDK a little bit easier
because you can also like main phone calls with
our client SDK stuff so I wanted to be able to
have something where people just put it on their
page and then you have a keypad so if you want
to make it make calls or maybe enter in a code
or what have you you don't have to worry about
it you just put that there and it does what it
needs to do and so these are some of the things
I used uh openwc which is a pretty cool uh like
framework for creating a web components it sets
up the structure for you and everything so that
if you're on a team everybody's on the same page
because there's a bunch of ways of creating
web components and so you can explore and find
something that you find that fits your needs but
if you're on a team you know just remove all the
choice just everybody's on the same page and we
can get this thing done and so openwc is pretty
cool for that and it uses lit which is like a a
rendering library for web components cool stuff
and then have all the different properties and
attributes on there so that you can change the
placeholder that's the text here and this this
is actually in my uh thing here this is working
because it's just a web page that I do for
my presentations and then we have the method
where you can create the action which will
turn this to the canceled event and then we
have some custom events here as well cool now
you've been asking yourself that's fine Duane
that's good for your little project little side
projects must be nice right you may be asking
well are web components a thing yet and I was kind
of asking that as well shouts to uh Westbrook J on
Twitter he put told me about this website our web
component's a thing yet.com and short answer yes
now I'm going to need some participation here I'm
going to scroll this page and every time you see a
logo of a company that you recognize please say
ding all right so you see a logo you recognize
I know there's like a delay with the
translation so you see a logo you recognize
all right cool so here we go
keep the things going nice thank you thank
you very much thank you for participation
now let's talk more specifically specifically
about like YouTube a lot of people use YouTube
right if you ever look at the source code of
YouTube you see all these random YTD things YTD
hyphen Rich hyphen grid hyphen row means nothing
to me but to them at YouTube it means something
and so that's a good way of saying like oh that's
a custom element because I have no clue what that
is so it must be something meaningful to them
that's why it's a custom element which is cool
so yeah all throughout YouTube GitHub they
actually created a set of web components
that you can use yourself called time elements
and so the way they use it is that if you ever
like push the change or like did a PR what have
you it'll say like however many seconds ago or
however many time ago those are web components you
can see right here it says like uh time hyphen ago
and so even GitHub is using it also in their uh
website now what about browser support you know
do you need like the bleeding edge of whatever
random browser nah pretty much any modern browser
has support for web components which is great all
right and then I have Source links you can check
out web components.org you know fact checking now
so how it is with react not so great now there's
two main things that web components kind of have
to do they have to handle data and handle events
so the data going into your web component and then
the events coming out of it now the current react
all data basically they handle like attributes
so they're basically strings so that's cool if
you're just using strings but let's say you
wanted to have like uh an array or an object
have you ever gotten that object object
thing the error which is just so frustrating
so that's what's going to happen now there's
ways around it and you can do it but it's kind
of a pain and then because of the synthetic
events system I think it's called you you
can't just listen for events coming out of like
uh elements normally you have to use like use ref
or whatever it was right but now this is how it
could be there's an experimental branch of react
how many people knew there was an experimental
branch of react exactly that's why I give this
talk and so uh I like I'm just trying to try
and gain like like uh awareness and just grow
awareness that there's this it's there like
it's there for you and so as you can see it
passes everything everything is great like even
the uh like the events you can have like was it
a camel case Pascal case snake case all the cases
and so it's fully supported it's kind of Awesome
so I kind of want to talk about like some of
the benefits of full support and I'm the type
of person I always like to think of others so I
won't somebody please think of the maintainers
because you have people spending their time like
their free time working on projects to kind of
make our lives easier right so why have them
work on a full set just for react right and so
because I'm not talking about me because with me
you're gonna get a pretty good uh like GitHub repo
that explains everything and how to use it and
everything even the diagrams this took me a while
to put together so you're gonna you're gonna know
how this works right and then also I write blog
posts so using web codes and react so I talk about
all the ways from class function to everything you
uh hooks everything all of it's here right uh
and you can always reach out to me on Twitter uh
we actually have like Community channels Advantage
so you can uh reach out to us there I do workshops
and um but I'm talking about people like Corey
lavisca this is a hero he has this really cool
shoelace web component library has anybody seen or
heard of uh or used shoelace it's pretty awesome
so that actually that web that uh QR code that I
showed earlier that was the shoelace web component
you just put on there so if you were looking to
generate web components easily this is uh pretty
cool but yes also it's kind of cool so I know it's
on the site so it's a forward-thinking library of
web components right and it says works with all
Frameworks all these things we're cdns blah blah
blah what I noticed was that first class react
support and I was like I had to reach out to him
and so on on the page look under react shoelace
offers a react version of every component to
provide an idiomatic experience for react users
uh you can easily toggle between HTML and react
examples throughout the documentation and you look
at angular and view they're literally the same
sentence except you replace angular and view plays
nice with custom elements you can use lace in your
angular apps with ease but you see how there's
all this other so I was like I reached out to
him on Twitter I was like yo are you not bothered
by having to like recreate twice double your work
him being the nice guys like no you know once
I do it once it's fine it's no big deal or what
have you but then he actually said one of the
biggest gripe is that he has to maintain now
two different examples with Demos in the docs and
so it makes working on these things much slower so
yeah let's think of the maintainers now what about
yourself you gotta think about yourself because I
don't know about you but it feels like sometimes
react makes you jump through hoops just to use web
components and if you like this I might make it
an nft and I'll put it up so anybody's interested
kidding anybody Okay cool so sometimes it just
feels like you have to go jump through hoops
to get it done so for example so this is I have
links to an actual working stack Blitz but this
is a piece of the code and so that's that use ref
that we spoke about before because react doesn't
have they create their own synthetic event system
thing so now in order to get your a reference to
your element you have to do use ref right and then
you have to use use effect to be able to add event
listeners to it and then you have to return the
things that remove the event listeners and then
this then you actually have the web component here
and you can see the action text is just a string
and that's a string but if I had to do like an
array I would have to do this other thing with
the thing and the current it's just a lot so
there's that but now how it could be that's it
you just put the element that's all and then
you just do the same thing and you have the on
digit hyphen added again with these the
snake case or however you want to do it
it's just that's it there's no use ref there's
nothing it's just that so uh with that said yay
boo boo
all right thank you you have to kind of like go
like remember these things I'm trying to make
you know different ways of remembering these
things all right so future proofing like I
mentioned before if you've used react you may have
remembered that just in version 16 there was like
three different ways of getting a reference
to your elements and you saw before if they
have full support you don't have to worry about
any of that so future proofing is another option
and then also styling because you know it's cool
to have your elements and they're all looking
like but what about styling everything right so
there's a couple of ways there's the CSS custom
properties who's used like it's also called CSS
variables who's use pretty awesome right now the
thing is is that I have this I have this example
here button so you just set the button and you
have like a background color then you have VAR and
then you have your variable that you want to use
for it and then like a uh like a fallback color
what have you now that's cool background color
what if you wanted to do the radius well then
you'd have like uh the radius and then you would
have like the bar and then you have that well if
you want to do the font color then you have the
font color and then that and the other thing and
if you want to do like font size and it's that
another thing whatever you may forget something
that you know like you want the person to use or
maybe you don't want them to be able to change
it it's all up to you but there's also the part
who sort of part see that's awesome right super
cool so same example except you name your thing
you put part and then you just give it the name
and part so like button I just called it button
because that makes sense but you can call it
Isaiah I don't know what color would you want
and uh so when your custom elements when you
define it you put custom element colon colon
part and the name of the part and then install it
however you want it's just that's it there's just
do what you got to do it's amazing so it's free
form which could be good or bad depending on I
like people have total say whatever they want to
look like stuff so that's just me but if you want
to have some control you can use the CSS variable
stuff all right so let's take a look at a couple
of examples all right so uh let's see here so
this is the VC uh text input so let's take a
look at HTML so you can see I just have a little
bit of JavaScript here so that you can tell what
to do with the VC text input and then I have
that placeholder again so let's say you want
to get aggro and you really want people to know
about the placeholder text and then uh hopefully
there we go all right now let's take a look at
the CSS so again I'm just going to remove this
so you see VC text input button and that's
this here I don't know why you want to look
like that but again do what you got to
do it's fine I'm not here to judge you
uh so yeah so you can see you can make it look
however you want uh next now this is the VC
members uh thing that I was talking about before
you know it's kind of it looks classic look you
know it looks clean looks nice but now what if you
want to do it's going to look that now that's rock
and roll that's just that's just awesome and so
uh so yes you can see I changed like the list
style disk I don't even know what people even do
that but I just did it uh then we all right then
also so the part each one of these L I call it Li
because they're Li's and I just change the color
to Black and the font side makes them larger now
sometimes you may have to run into issues where
you have to use custom uh CSS variables and so for
example I could not find a way to change like the
even and odd parts here using my part I just I
don't know if somebody knows away please let me
know but again as far as I understand it I don't
think there's a way and so uh so I just have my
you know BC members and child odd color and then
it's green and then blue so I was able to set it
using that way so sometimes you may need to use
both it kind of depends all right uh cool then
here's the VC keypad now check this out so how
it looks normally right just you know entering
numbers you know playing but what if you wanted
to turn it into like a keypad like a Gamepad
and uh bam oh wait no no and so then you can like
you know pew pew and shoot asteroids or whatever
that is that you want all right uh cool so I think
we're all here because uh we believe in the web
so I am once again asking you to uh believe in web
components and uh yeah so thanks for having me uh
I've created this random website because again I
create random websites and uh so web components.in
was available so I had to buy it and so slash
react for real and that list that goes to the
uh it it has a link to the actual GitHub like repo
thing where they're talking about the experimental
version so if you could like let them know like
hey we I think this is cool could we maybe you
know rush this out let's get this working because
I like web components I want full support you can
let them know and uh that's my website and uh
yeah and then uh that has a Dwane.in Vonage has
a bunch of links and stuff to like how to use web
components in various things and um yeah thank you